[Music]
in the past web analytics is not digital
analytics but web analytics was defined
as the measurement collection analysis
reporting of entering data for the
purpose of understanding and optimizing
web usage so as we saw in the first
lesson it's important to go beyond this
restrictive definition of what these
women outlets and embrace digital
analytics there are still component of
data collection measurement analysis
reporting and visualization so but the
difference is that we're not web-centric
we're not marketing centric we want to
use the right data in the right context
to inform business decisions so today is
the role of digital Animas is quite
different we are change agents as I
mentioned because we know how to make
sense of the data we want to bring it to
life and be able to convey an
understanding of what is possible so by
breaking something complex into smaller
parts again
we can also understand the constraints
and what is possible given the specifics
of your organizational environment
we're going to learn about the digital
analytics maturity model which is a
concept that I've created years and
years ago as a way to assess your
organization's trending weaknesses your
capabilities over various key areas of
maturity so this is how we're going to
look at people process and technology
but with a broader understanding of what
are the factors that will help you
succeed in digital analytics
so there are a couple of famous
guidelines I would say and one of them
came from Avinash Kaushik a number of
years ago it's called a ten nine year
old what it stated was that if you have
only $100 to span on digital analytics
ten dollars should be spent on the tools
and ninety dollars should be spent on
the people using those tools and you
know be it ten ninety or twenty eighty
the concept is that people are more
important in the tools and the great
thing is in this course you are
developing your skills as an analyst
you're going to be able to apply that
regardless to the tool so your value in
the market is going to increase so
analysts are you know we can extract
data from the tools there are tools that
will spit out a number of interesting
data and interesting reports but without
an analyst to really understand what is
going on you won't be able to provide
valuable insight things that the
business will care about so not just
data data is easy to get at a certain
point information is relatively easy to
get also but you need to go beyond that
you need to understand the business you
need to be able to provide actionable
insight another example of the guideline
again put forward by Avinash Kaushik is
the 20/80 rule about the work of an
analyst so ideally we would like to
spend a very little amount of time doing
just reporting because reporting is
typically available out of the box from
a tool and frankly anyone can go in it
to look at the numbers and make up their
own mind the analyst brings a lot more
value because of the unique skills of
the analyst to be able to bring context
to the data this sad reality and it's
true in digital analytics it's true in
business intelligence and other fields
we spend a lot of time getting the data
ready and very
time doing real analysis work so maybe
it looks more like this where you do
some reporting but you should also spend
time doing looking at the various
acquisition strategies looking at
understanding customer experience
looking at staying plug into the context
with you know understanding the business
the evolution of the business but it
could also be understanding the
evolution of our industry the digital
analytics industry and knowing that
there are new tools and concepts out
there that could be useful for your
analysis
exploring new strategic options to
influence the business and of course you
need some breaks and lunch in those
times so maybe the part missing here is
the sad reality that you could have
another circle that would go around
around this one that would be about
getting the proper x on the side to
collect the right information also
transforming and preparing all of the
data so you can actually do analysis
so what are the some of the mistakes
that we see most often when it comes to
digital analytics one of those is
failing to understand the issue of
integration the data collection itself
the tagging as we call it or integrating
data from the website with other data
source it takes a lot of time it is
complex failing to realize the limits of
unstructured data or we could even just
say fail to realize the limits of data
in the first place the different tools
have different ways of collecting the
data they have different meanings so you
could even end up with two metrics that
are very similar but somewhat different
because one come from a social media
source the other one comes from a
different tool and you try to match
those numbers and they simply don't
match the third mistake is to assume
that correlation has any meaning to
explain something and it's easy to find
correlation where there's actually no
relationship no meaning it's easy to
fall into some kind of self-fulfilling
prophecy where we seek the data that
will justify or satisfy our purposes
instead of the other way around and then
under estimating the labor skills needed
we often get told that such and such
tool are going to make the job super
easy and anyone can do it and so on but
it's not always true and yet some tools
can make our job easier but certainly
not easy and as the tools get better the
expectation the complexity of what we
have to work with is increasing faster
so there's always a lot of the men in
the market for people with the right
talent to leverage data
and expertise of course is super
important it's not about knowing how to
use a specific tool but it's about being
smart being intelligent being able to
exercise judgment and be able to apply
those skills in the way that you're
going to analyze data
so the team and expertise representing
is quickly represented by the way the
skills are structured within the
organization so how does the
organization structure its data and
analytics resource and team so maybe
there's no dedicated resources maybe
there's a project team again it's a
challenge because the project is
eventually going to end and those people
have signed through Project are going to
go back to their business doing
something else or maybe it's just a
part-time analyst and that's a challenge
because the field of expertise is so
complex that working on your own is part
time is very difficult so it's getting
better when you have a full time analyst
a distributed team so different skill
sets but reporting to different managers
while at level four you have a
multidisciplinary team of people working
for the same single manager and at level
five you reach a point where your
business stakeholders your users are
empowered they know how to get to the
information they need and they
understand what it means and it can make
decisions on their own
number four is by far the weakest spot
so there's some benchmark data about the
digital analytics maturity levels of
different organizations and by far it's
always the weakest spot so we want to be
able to have a methodology in place and
a process in place so that when we do
something we know the recipe so compare
that to a cookbook you can follow the
cookbook but it won't make you a master
chef here we want to be able to do is to
identify problems and important T's
we've looked at is this a nice and
provide insight if you don't have any
methodology every time you have to do an
analysis you start from scratch you
don't know how to do it maybe over time
you've defined your own way so first
time you do an analysis of your campaign
performance on Google search maybe it's
a little bit more difficult but over
time you know that oh if I have to do it
again this is how I do it it's good but
the problem is if you go on vacation or
if you leave the organization there's no
that knowledge is lost maybe as a team
as a group of people working together
maybe you have to find your own
methodology again it's not bad every
time you someone new comes to the theme
you have to train them there's a
learning curve while at level 3 if you
use a proven methodology and in this
course I'm going to show you a one-way
one Hooven methodology that can be used
to do an allocate the benefit is there
are probably training books resources
that you can leverage
even courses that you're going to be
able when you hire someone to say
knowledge of such-and-such methodology
is the criteria for this job at number
four you are agile but for online tasks
for example it is very likely that your
website has been developed with agile
development concepts in mind but how is
it that once the website is live we want
to do analysis and we don't use an agile
methodology to do our analysis that
doesn't make sense
but the rest of the organization maybe
is not as agile as the web environment
or the digital environment so that's why
at level 5 the whole organization is
agile be it for offline or online
processes so there is quick evolution
quick adaptation of the environment and
how to leverage that it's important to
note that agile doesn't necessarily mean
agile development as in developing
websites there's important aspect of
agile management which is the philosophy
of management so the agile methodology
that we're going to use is called Lean
Six Sigma and it has a couple of easy to
understand improvement steps that we can
go through it's a the benefit of gene to
Sigma it expects that well-defined set
of practice aiming at eliminating
defects so it used a lot of segmentation
of data slicing and dicing of the data
looking at it in different ways if you
like it is perfect for as a continuous
improvement process when the environment
is changing and evolving quickly but it
also has an in in its mindset the fact
that it's a collaborative team effort
that will lead success so let's look at
what are the DMAIC improvement cycle so
we start with define measure analyze
improve and control so the DMAIC acronym
is define measure analyze improve and
control so we're going to be able to
look into the details of each of those
step
but briefly what we mean here is you
start by defining what is the problem
you're trying to solve what is the
appointee you're trying to capture what
data is available and if it's not
available what
how will I collect it analyze we want to
find correlations and patterns in the
data in order to understand what's going
on and in the improved phase we want to
be creative in order to provide
recommendations that are both meaningful
relevant appropriate given the context
and control is once we've done those
changes we want to make sure that we've
actually achieved a sustainable
improvement we want to come back to it
and make sure that yes indeed we did
some we improve the outcomes
so the goal here is you might have seen
information in the past about the Sigma
and there's there are caveats there are
ways of using Sigma in different ways
and they have different training levels
you can be a green belt or a black belt
a bit like in karate but the precepts or
the concepts of Sigma are pretty simple
it has the user in mind all the time
when you want to deliver consistent
quality it is data-driven you want to
increase velocity and velocity is
improving the speed at which you deliver
value to the organization so imagine
that to the DMAIC cycle imagine that you
reduce the time between the moment you
find a problem on your website the
problem in the user experience you find
a problem and you reduce the time
between the moment you find the problem
the moment you solve the problem you've
just increased velocity you're providing
additional value faster to the
organization this thing more links that
Sigma also provides a lot of tools and a
good framework to get going quickly and
it allows you to quantify the complexity
of what's going on so all of that
readily apply to our environment so it's
really fascinating that to see that Lean
Six Sigma or Sigma was developed maybe
20 years ago and apply in an environment
for manufacturing but we can readily
leverage this expertise that will
develop over time and apply it in our
field so we don't have to reinvent the
wheel
the last dimension is the tools
technology and data integration and
interestingly enough this is probably
the one that has the least influence on
your ability to be successful with
analytics so we have this great saying
do not put your faith in what statistics
say until you have carefully considered
what they do not say so I don't mind
which tool you are using or how big your
big data is that's not what is really
important you can drink you can have a
lot of insight with small data and
simple tools it's all a matter of
balancing all the aspects of your
digital analytics practice so the
questions are it's not about which tool
you are using
it's about this level of sophistication
in the way you are using those tools so
maybe you don't have a tool that would
be the lowest level maybe you have
out-of-the-box solution like clickstream
analysis basic instrumentation basic
implementation of google antics for
example at level 2 you have defined
clear outcomes KPIs and dashboards
little three you are using segmentation
you are applying merchandising concepts
if you are an e-commerce website you do
a/b testing campaigning organization you
have defined personas KPI alerts so all
of that maybe if you are not familiar
with that terminology those are all
things that we're going to cover during
the course number four you use
multiplicity so multiple data source in
order to gain a better understanding of
what's going on you might be merging
different marketing data source doing
multivariate testing behavioral
targeting that would be an indication of
greater than three team and at level
five you use CRM data and data about
your customer with marketing you might
be doing predictive analytics and
evaluating the lifetime value of your
customers so this requires a more
sophisticated understanding of digital
analytics or analysis
concepts there was a global organization
in the gaming industry they decided to
group their twenty stakeholders and
including analyst managers and business
stakeholders and do an internal mini
conference where everyone would be
presenting a little something on what
they are working on so what we did is we
did a maturity assessment
individually so we asked everyone to
fill out a survey for those who are
managing analytics their perception was
that everything was pretty well advanced
pretty high level of maturity pretty
well-balanced accept the expertise and
they recognized that they were trying to
hire more people in the team and that's
why their expertise was lacking a little
bit so very strong very good level
when we look at who is responsible so
those are typically the analysts
themselves the picture was quite
different the picture was that most of
the aspects were low interestingly
enough expertise was at the same level
process was pretty high in technology
was very high but governance and
objectives were very very low compared
to the perception of the managers so
right there we see that there's a big
disconnect between the perception of
capabilities from one group the managers
to the other the people who are actually
doing the analysis and technology isn't
an issue it's actually higher than what
the manager felt because the annals were
saying we've got all the tools we need
that's not an issue and process was also
very high but then this came out those
informed people are their business
stakeholders and they are typically the
product managers of the games one of the
comment was really really clear it said
something like I get all those great
reports and they are very interesting
and I get recommendations but I don't
understand how they got there therefore
I don't really trust it so we see just
through this simple maturity assessment
involving different stakeholders we see
that the perception of capabilities was
very different so what is the solution
to a scenario like this the solution was
to for the managers to sit down with
their analyst and really explain this is
why what you do is so important this is
how it's going to be used this is how
the stakeholders are going to be making
decisions based on your data based on
your the information and the insights
you provide and based on the
recommendations you provide this was a
great way to engage the conversation and
then decide what is the action plan that
we want to do in order to identify what
is the expertise they need do they need
to hire someone new junior or senior do
they mean maybe someone external just
for a short time and hire a consultant
so on maybe what they needed actually is
not someone new maybe what they needed
is training in a specific area so that
they become more efficient so again the
solution did that was not a technical
solution it was just about communication
and change management so do they need
more training maybe yes maybe no what
kind of skills they should develop and
should they hire someone with those
skills already or just train people to
about those skills do they need every
elf or someone that will have a will be
on-boarded full-time what can they do to
educate and engage their stakeholders so
that they have a greater trust in the
data in the information recommendations
and so on so let's see how we have three
different areas of skills that we mean
to understand in order to be successful
as an analyst the first one is the
business outcomes and actions the second
aspect is the enabling capabilities and
the third one is analysis so let's look
in at each of those those aspects
so it starts with a strategy and some
goals that are communicated as business
requirements and objectives to people
who understand the technological
capabilities and constraints of the
various technologies that you're using
if you're building a website it's
different from building a mobile
application it's different from doing
advertising on Moton social media and so
on so those are the unique
characteristics of the technologies that
you are using people those people tends
to have a good understanding of the
information architecture what are the
functional components on your website
how to do tagging and how what is the
structure and what data is available so
those are more technical skills but what
they do is they make it possible they
enable you to have the means the tools
and the data so that's someone with more
of a statistical background problem
solving approach someone who is able to
synthesize a lot of information a lot of
data into something meaningful and
communicate effectively back to the
stakeholder and communicate actionable
insight and recommendations so when you
think of it think about you think about
what is your strengths in which area are
you the strongest is it on business side
is it on the more enabling technology
side of things is it more in statistics
and effective communication and things
like that
so typically every one of us we have one
strengths one very strong area we have
an area that we can manage we're okay
with that we can get along with it and
the third one usually is something that
either were not interested or we're not
skilled at doing so this reinforces the
importance of working as a team finding
other people who will be able to augment
your ability to have an empowered
analytics team and deliver more value to
the organization if you are consultant
consultant often do implementation of
digital analytics solutions so they are
in the enabling capabilities area and
their clients usually
know a lot more about the business than
they do which is perfectly fine so right
there it applies also to a consultant
versus client relationship where the
consultant is there to augment the
capabilities in some of those areas but
certainly not replace all of them
reinforcement of the fact that tonight's
are change agents there's really one big
difference between an analyst and a
manager the analyst has the privilege of
making recommendation but typically no
power of decision
imagine that you are the manager and the
analyst comes with the recommendation
you've made would you say yes to that
it's as the analyst you wouldn't say yes
to your own recommendation it's
obviously not a good one you need to go
back to the drawing board what are the
qualities of a good digital analytics
leader you have to have a breadth of
understanding you have to be able to
translate business requirements into
creative useful meaningful solutions a
good analyst is someone who ask
questions they don't go with the obvious
they want to go beyond that they have an
ability to understand what are the needs
of their stakeholders and propose the
right solutions but they also need to
have a depth of knowledge they need to
have some specialist area be it you know
technical skills or be it a depth of
understanding into a specific business
like automotive industry so you have
different knowledge in different
business disciplines are going to be
very important so think of the depth and
breadth of knowledge so the ability to
operate across different disciplines is
going to be important so are you someone
who understands statistics or are you
someone who understand statistics for
the automotive industry for example
that's different
so breadth versus depth of knowledge but
obviously again you won't be able to
master everything so depth of knowledge
versus breadth of understanding and here
in this course we want to expand your
breadth of understanding of the concepts
of digital analytics so that you're
going to be able to apply those concepts
in the specific vertical industry with
the specific tools so that will be the
death of knowledge
so focus is another aspect you need to
be able to make a distraction of what is
irrelevant and focus on what is really
meaningful for your analysis sometimes
we see that in analysis where it's going
a little bit all over the place and
eventually come up with a conclusion
that is not really well tied to the
analysis process that just went on
you are detail-oriented often time
motivation is what really excites you
about analytics in one way we can
consider that for example everybody
knows how to use Excel to do
spreadsheets about anything you can be
an expert at using Excel and being build
absolutely amazing spreadsheets or you
could be someone who knows about
budgeting and create a simple budget in
Excel so you don't have to be an expert
at the tool in order to leverage it so
which way are you is it more the thrill
of leveraging a technical tool to do
something absolutely amazing or is it
using the tool for simplifying your work
from a business end point
so you can look at what excites you
about analytics what do you think is
going to be the next big thing in this
industry sometimes you don't have to do
analytics all the time you have to
understand the concepts so that if you
need you're going to be able to find the
right resources to help you out so
there's some useful tools that you can
leverage the digital analytics
Association has for its members only it
has a tool that allows you to do an
assessment of your professional career
and provide you with some guidelines on
how to improve so just the fact that
you're taking this course is already a
very good indication of your desire and
ability to expand your horizon and learn
more about digital analytics so keep
going
a couple of key takeaways success
depends greatly on the digital maturity
of your organization but also of your
own skills you want to identify and find
what are your strengths and weaknesses
you want to balance the various areas of
success and you want to reap the maximum
benefit before you try to move on to the
next level the framework of the digital
analytics metric D model will help you
communicate or spark conversation I
think if there's one key element you
need to remember and we'll get back to
that is the define measure analyze
improve control cycle this is going to
be very useful and it's preferable to do
small incremental improvements with
using agile concepts rather than trying
to change big things and take big risks
that can easily fail the your own skills
and the team structure if you remember
the t-shaped breadth and death aspects I
think it's going to guide you in what
are your interest and what skills you
want to develop over time hey want to
become an expert in digital marketing
then subscribe to the simple learn
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn up and get certified in
digital marketing click here